it is your goodness that leads men to
repentance that causes men to change
their mind about you God
be a different side of your holiness
God we love you because you first loved
us how is this not mental illness Jesus
thank you for your Redemptive work it
was complete it was whole there was
nothing missing there was nothing
lacking there's nothing that you left
out Jesus nothing makes me respect
religious people less than when they
orchestrate conspicuous public prayers
for publicity genuinely and by the way
listen I don't care what Matthew says
but in Matthew 6 6 it does say when you
pray go into your room close the door
and pray to your father who is unseen
then your father who sees what is done
in secret will reward you